all right a couple of newsworthy items
that i want to touch on uh the trump uh
records that have been sent to the riot
committee the january 6th uh riot
investigative committee of the house of
representatives
some of those records were torn up and
taped back together and this is an mo
that we're already familiar with with
the trump organization and
administration the washington post
reporting
some records sent to the january 6
committee were torn up taped back
together mirroring a trump habit
when the national archives and records
administration handed over a trove of
documents to the house select committee
investigating the january sixth
insurrection some of the trump white
house records had been ripped up and
then taped back together according to
three people familiar with the records
former president trump was known inside
the white house for his unusual and
politically unlawful habit of tearing
presidential records into shreds and
tossing them on the floor
creating a headache for records
management analysts who meticul
meticulously used scotch tape to piece
together fragments of paper that were
sometimes as small as confetti as
politico reported in 2018 but despite
the presidential records act which
requires the preservation of memos
letters notes emails faxes and other
written communications related to a
president's official duties the former
president's infrangible shredding
practices apparently continued well into
the latter stages of his presidency the
national archives on monday took the
unusual step of confirming the habit
saying in a statement that records
turned over from the trump white house
quote included paper records that have
been had been torn up by former
president trump the statement comes in
response to a question from the
washington post about whether some
january 6th related records had been
ripped up and taped back together
this is about 700 pages of documents
transmitted to the january 6th committee
uh last months
now uh this
you might remember
that
not only ripping up documents is
something donald trump would frequently
do
there are
claims that trump ate documents
um
this is crazy but we reported on it back
in 2018 and it's all part of the same
thing
newsweek report trump eight sensitive
document
after cohen meeting former white house
lady claims uh former white house aide
omarosa manigault newman has said she
walked in
on president donald trump eating paper
after a meeting with lawyer michael
cohen
this is so insane in what she believed
was an effort to destroy sensitive
information this was from her book
unhinged an insider account of the trump
white house newman makes a series of
disturbing and amusing allegations about
the president's conduct
um newman recalls i saw him put a note
in his mouth since trump was ever the
germaphobe i was shocked
he appeared to be chewing and swallowing
the paper it must have been something
very very
uh sensitive so listen whether trump ate
notes or not
um there's no doubt at all like even if
omarosa is lying there's no doubt
whatsoever that the ripping up of the
notes was a common thing we reported at
the time that there was like a team of a
couple people that were their job was to
pick up confetti sized pieces of paper
and tape them back together to remain in
compliance with presidential records and
the like and of course this is not the
behavior of an innocent person and when
it comes to records about what happened
on in the lead-up to in the immediate
aftermath of the january 6th trump riots
why would he be ripping those up and uh
of course
um innocent until proven guilty all of
that stuff but this show is not a court
of law it's a court of opinion my
opinion and it is not in my opinion the
behavior of an innocent person last
thought on this
i don't have to remind you
that just about every promise that was
made
by donald trump leading up to his
administration
was a lie or it didn't come true
one of those claims was we will be the
most transparent administration ever
remember that trump had one press
secretary who held zero or one briefings
in her entire tenure it was a relatively
short tenure i admit
um and also remember that trump ran on
hillary can't be trusted
and is not transparent hillary's hiding
emails hillary deleted email hillary
used private email hillary can't be
trusted with sensitive information
hillary can't be trusted with classified
information and it all happened during
the trump administration trump spilling
secrets that were received from ally
israel to a russian spy recruiter in the
oval office remember that one
ivanka jared the whole team using
private email throughout their work for
donald trump in the administration and
on and on and on so there's five or six
stories here
and shockingly the one of trump eating
notes is not even the craziest or more
dangerous one